and this is a fox news alert on this
election night the polls are now
officially closed in new york new jersey
and the commonwealth of virginia where
all eyes are on the race between
republican glenn younkin and democrat
terry mcauliffe now coming up we have a
full packed hour county by county
analysis bill hammer at the big board as
well as the vote totals as they continue
to stream in keep looking at the board
on your screen this will be the most
important thing to watch all night and
keep in mind just last year joe biden he
won the commonwealth of virginia by 10
points now joe is underwater in virginia
by nearly 10 points that is a 20-point
swing and tonight what could be a clear
referendum on the deeply unpopular joe
biden and his administration the race is
now shaping up to be extremely close as
we speak democrats all across the
country are panicking according to exit
polls the economy was the top issue for
virginia voters and the economy is now
in a state of chaos we have historic
levels of inflation we have slow
economic growth we have labor shortages
supply chain issues and at the very core
of all of this is rising gas prices as
the president again begging opec and
russia to produce more oil he could ask
texas and
oklahoma anyway all in the name of
climate change and according to the exit
polls climate change well that ranked
near the bottom bottom for voters in
virginia in terms of their concerns and
meanwhile education was the second most
important issue for virginia voters now
this is terry mcauliffe's campaign
consisted of two things donald trump and
all of those racist parents who want to
have a say in their kids education how
dare they but tonight democrats might be
in for a rude awakening calling everyone
a racist blaming donald trump for
everything well it might not be the
winnable strategy they thought it would
be spending trillions of dollars on
socialist policies driving up taxes
inflation gas prices may not be so
popular cutting domestic oil gas
production in the name of climate change
while simultaneously firing american
energy workers giving vladimir putin a
waiver well virginia has not had a
competitive governor's race in 12 years
this race will go down to the wire that
we can tell you i'm steve ducey i'm
brian kilmeade and i'm ainsley earhart
and click here to subscribe to the fox
news youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis